nowadays many Americans say that my
country can no longer afford to play a
leadership role in the world and I agree
with
that in one respect the US can't afford
to play that role if we don't fix our
economy but the key to doing that is
making the right changes at home not to
withdraw from the world in fact I would
maintain we can't afford to withdraw no
matter how much natural gas we produce
no matter how comfortable we are at home
the world is still a dangerous place and
one that we need to worry
about back in 2012 there was a series of
debates among the Republican candidates
which were not memorable for very much
but I remember one
thing one of the candidates was asked
what he would do if he got a call at
3:00 in the
morning I don't I know why we have this
image in the United States that the
president gets urgent calls always at
3:00 in the
morning sometimes they come at
noon but anyway you get that 3:00 in the
morning call and they tell you that one
of Pakistan's nuclear weapons has fallen
into the hands of
terrorists that question is a very tough
one to answer and the answer would
clearly depend on the specific
circumstances but the very fact that
it's not an implausible question
demonstrates I believe just that one of
many reasons why we can't afford to
withdraw from the
world in a situation like that we must
be able to act indeed we need if at all
possible to act ahead of time to prevent
such a situation from
arising and if we do need to act we will
almost certainly need friends to help
us obviously and you're hearing from
someone who's had a long experience with
the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq there
is no question that two long
controversial Wars have been painful as
Wars inevitably are and they have made
Americans question our role in the world
for almost three years in Syria the US
seems to have been Paralyzed by a fear
that if we did anything at all that
would somehow lead to another Iraq type
involvement that fear is understandable
but not every situation needs to repeat
Iraq or
Afghanistan had we acted earlier the US
could have made a big difference in
Syria simply with more energetic support
for the moderate elements of the Syrian
opposition that would not have meant
going to war on their behalf but it
would have meant giving them financial
support medical support and yes weapons
and training as
well I We believe We repeated a
different mistake in Syria the mistake
of Bosnia in the 1990s and the mistake
in Iraq in 1991 at the end of the first
Gulf War
in Bosnia for three years under two
American presidents first President
George H W bush and then President Bill
Clinton the United States enforced an
arms embargo on the bosnians who were
the victims of aggression and who needed
weapons to defend
themselves that prolonged the conflict
and increased the
Bloodshed some estimates are the 200,000
people died in Bosnia during those three
years and it made the aftermath much
worse than it might have been if the
conflict had ended
sooner today Bosnia is at least at peace
but it's pretty much a broken country
partitioned in all but
name better than the war but if the war
had ended much earlier we could have a
different
story and I think that so many of the
bad consequences that people feared
would happen if we armed the Syrian
opposition have happened instead because
we did not having done practically
nothing while a bloody conflict raged
for 3 years it is now metastized into
what we see today a threat that some
judge to be even more dangerous than
Al-Qaeda was that's just one of many
dangers in the world and I think we
would do better to deal with them than
to run away from
them